Brazil right now is under a dictatorship
it's not it doesn't come from the
executive power it it comes from the
Judiciary there's no rule of law anymore
there's a rule of one person and this
guy that's what I what I said this guy
looks like a bad guy from James Bond
movies he's doing all that and he's kind
of crazy I don't care there's no one to
stop me right now and and that's the
situation right now there are a lot of
people in the streets right now as we
speak and they are they are desperate
they are like please someone do
something and of course they look at the
the military power because that's what
what's left but this is nothing new
though this is it's been going on for a
while wouldn't you agree that this this
is
much worse much worse but what do you
think what are you seeing actually
starting like at what point do you see
this power grab taking place internally
it's not a presidential level it's
somebody the body start taking power
taking control that's not something that
you can hide on the under the table
reflection points when Duma was in
pitched for example okay our
constitution listen I don't like our
Constitution that much it was written
one year before the Berlin Wall falls
down 1988 yeah so it's a very communist
Constitution but that's what we have and
the Constitution is very clear the 52
the 52nd article it's very clear when
you were in Pitch it you lose your
political powers for eight years so you
cannot be a candidate the the Justice uh
Lewandowski he just torn it down and
said no okay you can you can go and she
was a candidate to the Senate she lost
but she was able to be a candidate and
that what that was the inflection point
I think different rules uh roots to it I
mean when when Montesquie came up with
the three branches of power system and
and the framers of the U.S Constitution
they came up with the they put it in
place uh and and they they always
thought of about the Judiciary for
judicial branch as a the weaker one
right montesquis uh used to say that
they're next to nothing
uh the and The Federalist Papers
uh you you see them saying well there's
there's no risk of uh Judiciary
dictatorship because they don't have the
power of the purse or the power of the
sword so what do they have they're
they're bound to the loss and to the to
the to the common law
and and and that's the way they thought
the system well that's that that's good
enough if you think that the judge needs
to stick by the loss
checks and balances so if it went when
so when you have a textualist or or or
generalist or or journalists it's not a
thing uh originalist like Scalia so
they're bound to the intention of the
legislator
well if you have a progressive
view of the law the law is a living body
and the law with the purpose
teleological uh interpretation social
justice and all that social justice
you're not bound to that anymore so the
the N is what matters
okay so the means are irrelevant so if
you have to interpret the law and bend
it a little bit in order to achieve the
end that you desire
then things everything's permissible so
every judge is a dictator so my point on
the operation Car Wash and that brings
me to Sergio Moro is that I think Sergio
Morrow
uh
bended the law
to achieve his purposes and operation
Car Wash was a big inflection point in
my opinion against the due process of
lyme Brazil
and that's I I really believe that I I I
think bad guys went to jail which is
good but you don't have to only in
in the due process you don't have to
only be guilty you need to be prosecuted
under the due process of law and they
were not most of them were not and
Sergio Morrow and for political reasons
I believe and Deltona and other uh
prosecutors and they became politicians
and the the a good evidence for that
yeah is that that Serge Amora became a
minister and now he's a senatorial the
prosecutor is now uh uh uh Congressman a
congressman Congressman elect is this
guy can you pull up uh this picture so
the audience can see it is this guy
Alexander the more uh is he a feared man
I mean if you can do me the picture a
little bit yes he seems like a very
friendly guy
very friendly can I answer Patrick yeah
with a very straight answer I I'm not
going to Brazil anymore uh to visit none
of us I I have family there what happens
if you go to Brazil I'm afraid I'm
afraid I could be arrested for any crime
that they create would you say that this
guy is running the country yeah yes oh
yeah absolutely yeah he's run the
country yeah of course but he's not
alone like you look at him and you
understand there are a system a whole
system corruption structure behind him
he wouldn't do that alone come on he
looks like a James Bond Village yeah he
is it looks like it's it's probably the
haircut it's the haircut it's the way
that he behaves he's very weird he
behaves I believe he's a psychopath how
did he technically how did he get to
power what did he do before he was Tamer
uh he was Tamer uh Choice Minister of
Justice Minister and and he used to work
for look at that that's going to be
interesting he used to work uh to
Geraldo Alchemy who by the way is the
vice president elected with Lula so look
how impartial all that was in Brazil
Brazil our Justice you wouldn't believe
so one guy is the former lawyer of the
uh
uh Ms MST uh the the the how do I say
that we don't even have that in the
United States it's the government of
people that want to occupy uh land
like if you see a farm farm and they go
there and they go and the Invaders they
invade the land and they think there's a
legal movement correct of that in Brazil
Invaders okay uh so one of the their
lawyers is now one of the Supreme Court
Justices
a very weird uh pass I think we can say
that because we're in the U.S if if we
say that in Brazil right now we would be
in jail okay but he is his firm
um was lawyer of a company that was
accused of money laundry for Brazil's
largest drug cartel
uh that's that's a fact that's that's in
the news the conflict of interests are
huge in Brazil and and just for you to
understand the another very important
name to this discussion that we we
haven't brought yet is uh Rodrigo
Pacheco oh yeah he's the president of
the Senate and under the checks and
balances system that Paulo was talking
about it comes to this to the Senate to
impeach one of those justices they are
the ones that could stop this
dictatorship right now and Rodrigo
Pacheco who owns a firm a law firm that
has a lot of interests in in the Supreme
Court System a lot of decisions that
they they need to do to make and then
it's going to impact a lot his firms he
doesn't do anything he says oh
everything is normal in Brazil now
institutions are working perfectly we
don't need to worry about so it's like
this guy is a Trader right now he's a
Trader he he's accomplished of this
Alexander guy so with all the craziness
taking place I believe future looks
bright if you believe future looks
bright get your latest Future looks
bright hat of valuetainment it says
future looks bright here future looks
bright here we got them in white we got
them in Black we got them in red our
black on black sold out these are about
to sell out if you haven't ordered one
yet we had a person in Michigan but one
then he bought three then when those
three people wore it in the office they
had to order 58 of them because people
wanted the future looks bright hat
especially during times like this
because ain't nobody's saying future
looks bad toward your future looks
bright hat click over here and to watch
the entire podcast click here take care
everybody
foreign
[Music]